[Musik]
willkommen beim ein video ja leute ich
hoffe euch geht es gut mir geht's auch
voll gut weil heute wieder super
begleitung nicht spaßig eigentlich
komplettes gegen thun auf jeden fall wir
haben das schon 11 uhr es ist heute auch
der letzte tag und wir müssen in einer
stunde hier aus unserem tollen haus raus
wir waren gestern aber noch in der stadt
und waren in einem supermarkt und da gab
es ziemlich viele spanische süßigkeiten
und da ist der alex auf die idee
gekommen einfach mal diese süßigkeiten
zu probieren und zu kaufen
ich habe gestern ernsthaft 25 euro für
süßigkeiten ausgegeben ja also das ist
praktisch unser frühstück wir
frühstücken heute süßigkeiten und mir
das ganze ist hier in dieser
wundervollen boxring ich mir das mit
hüten
ach so und dann haben wir auch noch ein
pinkes haßberge von was wir auf irgend
einer art und weise mit kann dieser und
war die fresse halten auf jeden fall
haben wir das geholt weil ich dachte mir
so abhängig wird alex ganz gut stehen
und bei 20.000 likes bekommt alex
erstmal banker haare oder das war jetzt
nicht so geplant dass er sogar am rheder
das ding ist das bleibt auch nur einen
tag oder also man kann das rauschen oder
kurzen hallo
ob das wirklich nur einen tag drin
bleibt wollte ich schon einmal testen
wenn das nur ein tag drin ist doch egal
weil ich dunkle haare habe das geht
nicht so gut auf jeden fall willkommen
wieder zurück zum thema hier sind jetzt
die ganzen süßigkeiten drin das müsste
ich so zehn verschiedene sein oder
ja und ich würde sagen wir ziehen jetzt
immer abwechselnd irgendwas daraus und
probieren das einfach ein paar sachen
ich mein ich bin auch ein gespann ja
weil ich bin seit 19 jahren jedes jahr
in spanien habe schon viele spanische
süßigkeiten probiert aber einige war
nicht espanyol revieren auf jeden fall
kenne ich einige süßigkeiten davon schon
aber die meisten halt nicht so angesagt
anfangen
denn es ist doch so war sein lieblings
schließlich versucht das ding ist wie
heißt die zwei jetzt conchitas aber ich
kenne die unter anderen namen zwar
filipinos die haben wir auch noch geholt
glaubt mir das werden sich gleichzeitig
für die die gema schätzen dass wir die
erst am letzten tag entdeckt haben es
echt traurig ich war sogar schon
spannend da wo ich sonst mal war gab sie
dies ja einfach nicht warum zwar indem
sie vor zwei wochen direkt zwar gibt es
in münchen nicht locker doch aber nicht
so wie du gesagt was hast du gesagt
wünschen sich nicht locker gegeben
punkte die uns das beste und eins das
schlechteste was sozusagen als ich würde
sagen weil es letztlich die originalen
waren so wie ich sie kenne gebe ich nur
noch acht und zehn gehen canaria sie
teilhaben fünf euro gekostet als ehrlich
ich dachte hey wo hat macht ihm auch
jetzt leute was ich noch sagen kann
haben und zwar kam vorgestern die neue
weib kollektion online ist auf jeden
fall mal oben in der video beschreibung
verlinkt gibt neue coole klamotten von
mir schaut auf jeden fall mal vorbei
jetzt wagt die mal auf so leute
weitergeht wir haben die erste ich auch
bekommen aber jetzt haben wir darauf
gekommen ich würde sagen wir probieren
jetzt abwechselnd von jeder farbe du
darfst anfangen aber ich wollte auch die
den blauen anfangen denn die sind die
aua-maschine bonbon schaut euch das mal
an
merkst du das überhaupt so was meinst du
ich mag noch so gar nicht wenn du also
diesen echt geil oder die grünen sind am
ende war die grünen sind lecker kann es
auch versuche warte ich werde mal
weggehoben du fängst du auch okay noch
mal den tropen
doch was du denkst du du bist doch
zuzugeben dass vorher bestand
ich sag auch auf ein getränk getränke
sollte das nächstes ein getränk und zwar
im tor für sie ich habe keine ahnung wo
nach das schmecken soll aber das ist uns
herausfinden muss herausfinden was soll
ich anfangen nämlich noch die band i
das schmeckt sowie und dann erst das
schmeckt nach kaugummi ja auch noch
kaufen
ich finde das gar nicht so schlecht
bestellt das scheiße also da bin ich
traurig was wir zu sagen welche note
ich sag 2 also ernsthaft so schlimm dass
ich war folglich so leute ach so ich bin
mir dran ist hat im aldi tüte hindere
okay leute ich habe eigentlich das
gezogen wovon ich gestern glaub ich am
meisten begeistert war und zwar sind das
tool soll das ist ein euro vergünstigt
ich finde ihn auf jeden fall mega lecker
und was die beste aus ihr gesicht oder
die teile dein gesicht afghanistan marie
folge meint worden die sind schon leicht
geschmolzen aber auch nur ganz leicht
war das erinnert
das erinnert mich voll einen baumkuchen
mehr gut
[Musik]
also da muss ich sagen deutsche sollte
auf jeden fall mit 10
wenn ich muss mal kurz im pool mainburg
mund waschen
wir machen weiter bin ich dran aber du
nicht du bist dann ist weihnachten
geburtstag zusammen ja da habe ich mit
major leagues nochmal auf faule leute
schaut euch das mal bei schlecker villa
trips noch einmal auf
[Musik]
falls ein wirklich marco kurz und was
den gerichten 7
aber es ist nicht so gut so leicht ich
bin dran gib mir die tüte und zwar wohl
ich jetzt hier aus erreichen braucht die
kinos kommen jetzt probieren so leute
das hier ist jetzt das originale
philippinen oder die originalen
stilistik sehen war glaube ich nur ein
abklatsch diesen gleich gespielt von
jetzt glaubt mir ich anderen ja das war
schade ich habe diesmal mit weißer
schokolade gegessen
die gibt es hier nicht ohne spaß ja
blogger in meinem leben schon 1000
klicks von denen hier gegessen
den gebe ich nur 1 19 vielleicht steht
was sagen wir so noch nicht gesehen
ich gebe mich gibt den anderen neun
obwohl eigentlich muss ich den zehn em
medaillen 9
man wird das getränk weil ich ja voll
durch
so leute das nächste ist rubicon hua
sparkling mit julianna artifiziell
smetanas suite abele für vegetarier das
gericht das vegetarische war das riecht
übel süß war etwas ganz davon halten
sein
so ist auf jeden fall sehr trocken
dezent angenehm ich finde das ok also
ich würde sagen du kriegst eine
siebeneinhalb das hat die gleiche farbe
wie das heißt also wenn ich mal sagen
wir haben noch so 34 sachen drin
ich nehme es als nächstes einfach mal
die sind mega der adula bonbon der agora
bonbon bei mir wird schon schlecht von
dem ganzen zeug
[Musik]
also ehrlich zu sein es ist gar nicht so
schlecht oder aber es ist auch nicht gut
das nicht gut 160 grad ohne wird das
nächste ist millions was auch immer das
sein soll das prickelt wahrscheinlich um
und oder müsste es eigentlich alles mal
aus der packung essen
ich mach das mal hier in die hand schon
komisch überträgt den märkten täglich
alkohol braucht man kriegt man echt
zahnschmerzen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
woher die bleiben fallen ins heim geben
so ich habe das geschafft was klein
begann sie deswegen gehirn welche jedes
größere muss man probieren wir mal das
lecker ob ihr doch mal okay leute ich
konnte nicht mehr weiter also ich bin
jetzt raus das hier ist das erdbeer guck
mal das ist das gleiche das doch mal in
die kamera
das ist das gleiche wie beim lakritz
leben wir noch mal fahren wir auch gut
da auch die diesen sport
also da muss ich sagen verdient er ich
würde sagen ein so leute das kriegt
einen punkt zusammenfassend lässt sich
sagen die hier sind am besten wer setzt
sich nach deren meinung gespalten
also ich muss sagen dass es am besten
und du sagst auch das ne und die canaria
rias sind auch gut canaria das ding ist
aber halt auch die haben fünf euro
kostet soll das war unser spanische
süßigkeiten test ich hoffe ihr hattet
spaß beim anschauen es war auf jeden
fall witzig und werde ich das vielleicht
irgendwann auch mal mit chinesischen
süßigkeit machen soll oder mit indischen
süßigkeiten oder mit russischen
süßigkeiten dann lassen wir noch nach
oben da und sagen wir mal auf der marie
könnt ihr auch bei instagram folgen wenn
ihr wollt und wir sehen uns dann morgen
wieder wir fliegen jetzt gleich jetzt
zurück nach deutschland also wenn ihr
das video sehen bin ich schon
deutschland hat rein müssen noch sagen
okay besser nicht